o papa o lado pessoal de quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo é mais um
vídeo e os estragos equipe finalmente
fight night at freddy's 3 finalmente o
nosso mix 4k ontem civil soltar o demo
eu estou superansioso tipo maluco eu
ainda não vi nada sobre este jogo única
coisa que eu sei e todos falam por aí
ex postumamente vai ver um novo
animatrônico que é este exame não está
aqui no menu que a descer tipo gol em
bola em alguma coisa sim por sida e não
saiu não faço ideia vamos ganhar no
grito super ansioso eu possa
experimentar ok meia-noite primeira
noite
vamos lá a conferir não é factível o
caso longa da série
só temos a faltar inspiração meio
turbulento tipo louco com este jogo até
câmera estava o fred eu vi o fred e ele
em cima
vou prestar atenção a chamada a boy azul
claro esteve a intenção é ficar aqui tem
muita coisa nova e tem muita coisa nova
tem áudio tem câmera tem resolução não
tem que prestar atenção muita coisa
o boni piscar é meu isso não me agrada
nada nós vamos ter que prestar atenção
muita porcaria e entretanto já proíbe
completamente
é o que é que o zé manel da chamada está
a dizer
ó o que eu soube explicar o que
aconteceu com o painel disse que o mais
importante é prestar atenção a intenção
é que né
a ventilação é isto ok eu agora tem de
vários sítios por controlar tenho as
câmeras tenha ventilação e ainda tenham
lhe uns painéis que eu não sei porque
aqui serve para controlar o áudio as
câmeras de ventilação tipo não sei muita
coisa já que meu reboots uol eu não sei
se devo fazer isto já não sei se vou
fazer porcaria mas ok sou assim também
já eu vou passar a primeira noite assim
se acontecer nada
o gato leste houve alguma coisa espera
espera espera que josé bonin o cinema
tronics antiga estão aqui tudo é
arrumadinho o que se passou seis da
manhã ok conseguir passar a primeira
noite assim - nada só ouvia chamada e
ver as coisas novas
ok é primeira opção é os antigos
eletrônica estão todos depoimento dado à
luz dentro da caixa de texto e temos
muita coisa pra controlar e também temos
mais uma vez os épicos mini-games só que
ainda lá nós temos o fred só que em uma
página tá chovendo aqui dentro do
governo contas da água que irá putanesca
não sabe o tamanho aquilo que eu sei mas
acho que o pouga e acho que se chama al
qaeda não eu vou ter que seguir é porque
o chinelo botafogo x paraná sozinho
caiana lá eu não consigo inspirado por
cima erro e um erro sai uma turma é uma
turma de teatro na bizarra meia
noite-noite 2 só que nós queremos passar
a primeira noite muito rápido e não fará
a segunda noite ouvir o que eu tenho
como dizer eu vou tentar prestar atenção
lembra
o pessoal que não e pizzaria está agora
em um parque de diversões então que o
cinema tronics exposto domingo todos os
comentários mas é como falar do áudio
olá
isso aqui é o tamanho do fazer pizza
voltou a vencer depois de um toque
eu já não já não perceber nada meu lugar
não takita não não não fui eu em calma e
tamanhos não tenho diz que não dá pra
fechar a porta o que com certeza que
nada nada e só consegui morrer aqui
calcula a chamada acaba deixando
deixando prestar atenção ao jogo
eu ainda disse prew sorrir meu como é
que é possível subir nesses ambientes
vim à lusa manuel 21 chinesa han xinyun
han xinyun calma calma é que cada uma é
a ventilação isso temos temos claro rico
foi o da força total em 2010 não houve
alguém ali passaram como fez isto como é
que eu fiz não foi chata fashion
não dá eu morrer agora eu tenho que
botar as coisas estranhas no rio e um
fio
meu caso é muito clipe é muito crível tá
ali não tem flash lite não importa já
não tem o lúcio não tem nada meu outra
faca e pouco e joguei este mudaram muita
coisa precisa de alguma coisa escrita
tem ventilação andar onde estava em
relação é que nem aí é supostamente se o
cara aqui duas vezes faixa não não saiu
não sei o que tenho que fazer aqui
ok primeiro susto no firefight fredes 13
pessoal pede desculpa mas não se
desligar meu eu não se desgastou por
queria isso tem muita coisa nova eu vou
tentar outra vez mais pessoal digam me o
que é que eu tenho que fazer o que é que
eu tenho que prestar atenção que é mais
importante a fazer
eu nem percebi bem as chamadas porque
estava atento ao jogo mas é isso pessoal
quanto após ajuda eu vou tentar jogar
outra vez e vamos ver se consigo passar
esta noite dois
eu acho que podemos também é só a
segunda noite por isso é uma onda agora
que está tudo bem a que mais criou josé
pinto meu isto é tão querido você pagar
sua mãe news estão espalhados por todo
lado
alguém fez alguma coisa gm tronics
antigos mil
o resultado faz o deputado ítalo a
equipe é a única que conseguiu foi por
pouco foi por pouco que eu já percebi
esse painel serviu para afastar
aquilani matrone daqui não sei ainda
quem anima tronic é que os postos também
ter um bumbum bonito porque parece-me
born antigo mas gol da equipe não saiu
não sei nada steel camisa' a ruta muito
mais complexo já burrico é calma calma
camargo em tudo que eu não morri meu
pela primeira vez não familiares é
fredes atestaram eu não morri como como
está muito mais companhias ficam mais
ventilação ficção do que precisa de
intervenção não é que também não é que
onde
não não quer subir não vou sair daqui
sem passar esta noite dois já sabem
pessoal do mundo máxima systems comigo
um crime embora lalo ninguém 82 outra
vez vamos ter que passar esta [ __ ] e
bora lá eu não percebi também ao certo
para que serve o risco do zé do baú
supostamente participaram animatrônico
mas acho que isso não funciona muito bem
o camisa 20 lançam tem de controlar a
inflação não lavar a área que tem de
controlar isto não pode esquecer avançou
nesta sala não está aqui
ela que é o que eu tava só comprar fora
mas tá aqui ó que desapareceu depois e
agora possui agora meu bairro eu custar
um olho e ou desaparece logo eu como é
que é possível obter avançar por uma
destas células
ok ok ok ainda através de rui verde um
error viu o erro de um erro aqui ok
agora acho que fui rápido o suficiente
para eu não uma estada
são três da manhã
isso isso é quem vai encarar em casa o
vitória foi assinada que até agora vamos
continuar assim prestar atenção não
estava aqui
sobe rápido quanto de manhã eu tô quase
a passar a noite eu falava falava lá foi
campeão então eo fluxo rodoviário lê o
filme espírita na janela meu eu não vou
aceitar esse papel eo que não está
a lei é isso aqui não saiu não consigo
perceber seu talento mas já perdi de
vista já previsto no edital de
contratação 15 da manhã passou agora
para as cinco da manhã mas não ser é
claro agora não sei nem cantar cinco da
manhã deu a prefeitura passa passa passa
passa lá também o costa nem quase lá eu
vou ficar aqui à espera de quase uma
hora de duração
só que a sorte eu ouvi ventilação eu
tava dentro da ventilação pronto pra mim
eu estarei eu consegui passar esta
segunda à noite
vamos ver se também a terceira agora
ninguém vai caindo lá
agora o foco mini-game aparentemente tem
um enigma cada a cada noite típica lado
e eu agora sou bom nisso boni agora meu
eu não sei o porquê de verão em renan e
michel se planar mande ep itália para
jogar outra vez um tamanho está a porta
vai matar
vamos acabar tudo morre eu já saí é por
isso que hoje metrô em santiago estão
todos mortos porque foi o polga que nos
matou dia por isso não estamos ali
dentro daquela caixa faz sentido faz
sentido foi o pai que fez aquela
porcaria toda e não sei se o zé da
câmara já tinha dito isso
josé da câmara não 10 é chamada
eu não sei se eu já tinha dito isso não
prestei muita atenção mas pela lógica é
o quarto lugar está a matar o pessoal
tudo meu ok terça à noite então é isso
pessoal nós não ficar porque com este
vídeo fight night at freddy's três já
sabem eu vou continuar esta série como
sempre o fisco faz nas sete prédios
porque é um jogo épico voz flea kfouri
disse para ter um estado fiquem bem e
até a próxima
ae